you were talking about the Royal Rumble
coming up so explain that to everybody
who who doesn't know what that is so the
Royal Rumble it's a it's a PL of ours
it's one of the the biggest ones of the
year it's one of our favorite ones it
jump starts The Road to WrestleMania so
it's unpredictable I always like to
describe it as a mixture between the
past the present and the future and what
it is is 30 women in one ring it starts
out with two women and every 2 minutes
or so another woman comes out and no one
knows who it's going to be so it's very
unpredictable it can be a legend someone
from the past it could be a current
Superstar it could be one of the women
from one of the de developmental um
programs that's considered the future it
could be Kelly Clarkson it could be
anyone exactly you don't want me in that
ring it could be anyone I got a lot of
inrage you don't want you don't want to
unleash this you got to harness it and
use it there you go Kelly Clarks said
the Royal Rumble but the way to
eliminate someone you throw them over
the top rope uh So you you're trying to
throw people over the top rope people
trying you over the top rope and the way
you win is you're the last woman
standing and if you're the last woman
standing then you get an automatic title
match at WrestleMania so it's a huge
deal it's one of my favorites I actually
won the Royal Rumble uh the year that I
got to Main Event WrestleMania so it
changed the whole trajectory of my
career I want an espb off of that match
so it's an exciting time of the year it
can change someone's career it can
change their whole entire trajectory
it's just an amazing uh match to watch
yeah super exciting I love the drama of
not knowing who's coming yes yeah for
someone who doesn't watch Like Christmas
dinner when people are bringing
dates like who will it be be this year
will they make
it all right we have to do a quick
commercial break you can see WWE Royal
Rumble 2024 January 27th exclusively on
peacock and also love and WWE Bianca and
montz is streaming on Hulu from February
[Music]
2nd
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home